servus sg zum herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute möchte ich mit
euch jetzt schon viel gesehen über geld
reden und nicht nur über geld sondern
ganz speziell über konsum jetzt
vielleicht okay was ist eigentlich
konsum konsum kommt von lateinisch
consumer das heißt verbrauchen verwenden
verzehren dürfen eine schlaue notizen
ihr sagen und bezeichnet im allgemeinen
verbrauch von gütern das heißt zb
shopping will dazu zählen sich die shows
zu kaufen sie beim bmw zu kaufen ich
habe keine ahnung zählt auf jeden fall
auch zu konsum aber auch zb nutzen von
dienstleistung für die mehrzahl hat wie
zb taxifahren oder der gang zum friseur
wenn man mal so drüber nachdenkt was
eigentlich alles zu konsum dazu zählten
das ist wirklich eine ganze ganze menge
dann merkt man dass wir deutschland in
der regel jeden tag konsumieren und
manchmal auch gar nicht so bestätigt
dann stellt sich natürlich die frage wie
viel konsumieren wir eigentlichen dann
kann man sich fragen ob wir in einer
konsumgesellschaft leben also quasi in
einer gesellschaft leben oder in einem
land leben wo extrem viel konsumiert
wird und im konsum ein sehr hoher wert
zu kommen ist die frage bohren kann man
festmachen dass man in der
konsumgesellschaft lebt hinweise darauf
sind zum beispiel die massenproduktion
von produkten oder masten absatz von
produkten das herstellen von
wegwerfprodukte das heißt hier kauft
euch produkte die quasi nur zwei drei
wochen oder ein paar monate halten ein
kaputt gehen und ihr euch schon wieder
neue produkte kaufen müsst also schon
wieder konsumieren willst und das system
ist darauf ausgelegt das produkt ist
vielleicht darauf ausgelegt und ein
weiterer hinweis könnte sein dass man
mehr konsumiert als man braucht wenn man
sich mal überlegt was der mensch
eigentlich braucht also damit meine ich
nicht so ich brauche unbedingt die
neueste serie von aus of cards oder ich
brauche unbedingt ein rumpsteak abends
dann merkt man dass der mensch an sich
eigentlich relativ wenig braucht der
mensch braucht was zu essen was zu
trinken vielleicht noch ein dach überm
kopf gesundheit familie und so weiter
und so fort aber viel davon seien dinge
die man sich nicht kaufen kann was dinge
angeht die man sich kaufen kann braucht
der mensch tatsächlich eigentlich nur
sehr sehr wenig und trotzdem geben wir
sehr sehr viel geld für konsum aus und
kaufen alles sie fahren natürlich woher
kommt das gefühl was zu brauchen jetzt
gerade mir schon gesagt manchmal hat man
einfach das gefühl dass man jetzt
irgendwie coole klamotten braucht man
hat das gefühl dass man irgendwie die
neue serie kaufen muss wenn man sie
nicht illegal stream natürlich was ja
stattfinden sollen aber zb in bezug auf
justin so justin denkt sich vielleicht
man ich brauche unbedingt
die neueste kollektion bode ja jemand
jetzt richtig viel zockt denkt sich
vielleicht man braucht unbedingt diese
gaming tastatur ich brauche unbedingt
die beste keine ahnung rocket racer
tastatur für 200 euro die brauche ich
einfach unbedingt in die frage ist woher
kommt das gefühl dass zu brauchen weil
eigentlich braucht der mensch aufgrund
seiner veranlagung keine röcke tastatur
zum überleben meine meinung dazu ist
dass sehr viele bedürfnisse also das
sehr auf der glaube was zu brauchen von
außen erzeugt wird gutes beispiel dafür
sein wie gesagt zb so fancy gaming
tastaturen oder hude so teure klamotten
weil wie gesagt der mensch braucht sowas
nicht zum überleben wenn ihr euch
irgendwie menschen vor steht der quasi
in der wildnis lebt der braucht sicher
keine 800 euro polizei über leben und er
braucht auch keine 200 euro tastatur zu
überleben sondern der braucht zum
überleben einfach wasser und essen
natürlich will heutzutage keine meldung
mit wasser und essen lieber was ich
meine ist dass man darüber nachdenken
sollte ob man das wovon man denkt dass
man braucht auch wirklich braucht im
allgemeinen ist es so wenn der kohle
verdient habt oder generell geld habt
dann habt ihr im wesentlichen drei
möglichkeiten damit umzugehen
ihr könnt entweder sparen wurde ihr
können konsumieren oder feldmann dritte
möglichkeit schulden abbezahlen mit
reald natürlich ist es klar dass
unternehmen die euch gerne produkte
verkaufen wollen weil sie damit geld
verdienen wie zum beispiel dm oder baby
baby ist in dem sinne eigentlich auch
unternehmen mit blue oder h&m mit einem
t shirt oder porsche mit dem auto die
unternehmen haben natürlich interesse
daran dass ihr euer geld für ihre
produkte ausgibt machen dementsprechend
werbung um euch das gefühl zu wecken
dass er die produkte braucht oder
generell euer interesse fürs produkt zu
wecken das heißt aber auch dass wir in
der richtung ein großes ungleichgewicht
haben wir haben auf der einen seite sehr
sehr viele unternehmen die einem das
gefühl geben dass man die produkte
brauchte die darauf hinarbeiten einem
das gefühl zu geben dass man die
produkte braucht diesen machen aber auf
der anderen seite eigentlich niemanden
der sagt hey denkt mal darüber nach
brauchst du jetzt wirklich den porsche
oder brauchst du wirklich den 800 euro
pulli oder brauchst du wirklich diese
teure tastatur
die gibt's irgendwie gar nicht deswegen
möchte ich gern so ein video machen was
in die richtung geht um einfach euch war
somit zu geben es gibt auch noch eine
möglichkeit einfach nein zu sagen zu
konsum ganz klar und teilweise zu
einfach ein gutes gefühl mal das geld
nicht auszugeben auch um man vielleicht
lust drauf hätte allerdings ist die
frage ob ich konsumiere oder nicht nicht
immer eine freie entscheidung ich
studieren wirtschaftswissenschaften in
den wirtschaftswissenschaften gibt es so
ein modell das sagt es gibt eine gewisse
menge an konsum in gewissen grund konsum
das kann man sich zum beispiel
vorstellen wie lebensmittel die ein
mensch unbedingt zu überleben braucht
ihn jeder mensch hat und wenn man quasi
diesem grund konsum nicht tätigt kann
man nicht überleben und deswegen ist
dieser grund konsum auch keine option
das heißt den muss jeder machen aber was
wir nicht vergessen dürfen ist dass
viele leute nicht die möglichkeit haben
über diesen grund konsum hinaus noch
groß ausgaben zu machen weil sie
vielleicht einfach nicht das geld dafür
haben weil die kohle knapp ist und weil
nach dem zahlen der miete zum beispiel
und nach dem bezahlen von essen &
trinken für den ganzen wohl einfach
nicht mehr viel übrig bleibt das heißt
nicht jeder hat quasi die möglichkeit
sich für oder gegen konsum zu
entscheidend und manche leute einfach
nicht genug geld um eine entscheidung
treffen zu können
für die heißen sondern einfach nein die
möglichkeit ja zu sagen gibt es nicht
erst durch die frage wie ist das mit
vegetariern wie ist es mit veganern sind
es auch leute die auf konsum verzichten
weil ihr eigentlich darauf verzichten
fleisch zu essen beispielsweise kümmert
sagen okay die verzichten auf fleisch zu
essen deswegen sind als konsumverzicht
da ist natürlich die frage ob sie das
geld was sie natürlich durch sparen dass
die kein fleisch kaufen dann tatsächlich
für sich behalten also sparen sparbuch
tun oder ob sie das an anderer stelle
ausgeben weil wenn sie das denn genau so
an anderer stelle ausgeben und zb die 80
euro monatlich kostet hätte dann in
teure vegane lebensmittel investieren
dann verzichten sie in dem sinne gar
nicht auf konsum sondern geben ihr geld
einfach anders aus ja das thema
konsumverzicht ist ein sehr sehr sehr
großes fragezeichen ich hab das vor ein
paar jahren für mich entdeckt und ich
habe mir als ich kauf mir ganz ganz ganz
selten klamotten eigentlich also
wirklich wirklich wirklich selten max
dagegen mein kleiner bruder den kennt er
ja alle der gibt gerne viel geld aus für
klamotten und das ist auch absolut cool
kann er gerne machen aber ich bin
einfach ich habe recht sparsam geworden
so irgendwie letzter zeit keine aber
vielleicht ein paar von euch das auch
das gefühl und dann kann man sich
vielleicht auch noch fragen ok welchen
effekt hat das auf die wirtschaft also
quasi auf die wirtschaft in ganz
deutschland wenn jetzt alle leute auf
einmal anfangen weniger zu konsumieren
das ist vielleicht eine relativ klare
sache denn wenn alle leute auf einmal
auf einen schlag weniger konsumieren
dann will das auch bedeuten dass
unternehmen die die produkte verkaufen
die leute konsumieren auf einen schlag
weniger umsatz machen und
dementsprechend vielleicht weniger leute
beschäftigen können und vielleicht
weniger löhne zahlen können und dann
letzten endes die leute einfach weniger
cola
andererseits gibt auf der welt aber auch
nur sehr begrenzte ressourcen und es
gibt ja dieses berühmte zitat ich weiß
nicht was war das gandhi der gesagt hat
die welt bietet genug für jedermanns
bedarf aber nicht genug für jedermanns
gier und das heißt eigentlich wir müssen
verantwortungsvoll mit den ressourcen
hier umgehen und daraus könnte man
schließen dass man eigentlich auf konsum
verzichten sollte wenn man den film
bringt braucht also dieses ganze thema
ist gar nicht so leicht aber ich finde
es sehr sehr wichtig darüber
nachzudenken und zu guter letzt der
durchschnittliche europäer besitzt
10.000 dinge 10.000 das ist eine ganze
menge wenn ich mit meinem zimmer hier
umschaue würde ich vielleicht nicht
denken dass hier einfach 10.000 dinge
rein passen dass mir 10.000 dinge
gehören und leute zum ende werde ich
jetzt versuchen zu beantworten welche
zehn dinge ich behalten würde wenn ich
nur zehn dinge haben könnte und ich
würde sagen auf jeden fall mein laptop
ganz wichtig meine sportschuhe richtig
richtig geiler ordentliche laufschuhe
weil ich laufen und sport einfach geil
finde und das wichtig ist für mein leben
bücher weil ich sehr sehr gerne lese
ec-karte ich das eigentlich klamotten
fakten pullover 50 hose sechs socken
unterhosen krass einer wiese marin kommt
eine jacke und eine sache habe ich noch
mein auto selbstverständlich auch noch
ein bisschen dieses auto short gegangen
ist ruhe in frieden auf jeden fall ein
auto ich habe mich in letzten tagen echt
ans fahrrad fahren gewöhnt wie gesagt
man autos kaputt ich weiß mit einer
fahrrad aber ich finde auto von einfach
so geil das ist dass das werde ich nie
öffnen rausbekommen ich finde auto
fahren einfach geil auch wenn die
überhand absolut klar kommen autofahren
ist einfach keine ahnung ist mein ding
der leute jetzt zum abschluss die frage
welche zehn dinge würdet ihr behalten
wir nur noch zehn dinge behalten könnte
treibt dass man die kommentare allein
macht's gut